it's one thing and it's bad enough that
they cut Trump out of context and lie
about him it is also bad enough that
there are people who support Trump that
make fake things and then they get
shared by people in the trump in the
Trump camp like in in like the Trump
Circle and things like that but to
intentionally run an ad with fake images
to smear your political opponent is
crossing the line directly and it opens
the door to a very dark future that's
why it's like hey we knew someone was
going to do it Rhonda Santa said he was
going to lead out but man it says re
that this is real it says real life real
life Trump with a picture of him that is
not real life Trump so good God what did
you guys do this really opens up the
floodgates for RFK to do it to ads
against Biden right I just we were
talking about this before the show and I
was just saying I can't imagine Trump's
going to run ads Trump is going to make
an ad and it's going to be it's going to
be like some woman it's gonna packs are
gonna do this so if you're gonna hear a
woman go Ron desantis's campaign is
making fake images of trump to smear him